Alec Baldwin's legal fight in the Fatal
rust shooting has only just begun
welcome everyone to Entertainment
Tonight Kevin Frazier has the night off
the tragedy that killed cinematographer
Helena Hutchins over a year ago has now
entered its next phase with two powerful
words involuntary manslaughter
there's only one question to ask here
who put a live round in the gun he
didn't check it and then he pointed the
gun at Helena Hutchins and he pulled the
trigger both Alec Baldwin and Hannah
Gutierrez read will be charged with two
counts of involuntary manslaughter 44
minutes after prosecutors announced
charges Alex attorney fired back calling
the decision a terrible miscarriage of
justice and vowing we will fight these
charges and we will win there's a lot at
stake both individuals could be facing
up to five years incarceration yes the
case could end up in the hands of a jury
and today we learned more about Alex
possible defense strategy it's supposed
to be
Alex attorney said Mr Baldwin had no
reason to believe there was a live
bullet in the gun or anywhere on the
movie Set he relied on the professionals
with whom he worked who assured him the
gun did not have live rounds the other
argument Alec Baldwin has made is not
only that he didn't know that the gun
was loaded but that he didn't hold the
trigger he said this on an interview
with ABC the trigger wasn't pulled I
didn't pull the trigger and the problem
with that is the investigators brought
in individuals that's sole expertise is
in ballistics and their finding was that
that gun could not have gone off without
him pulling the trigger I don't know if
this is suspected blood or real blood
this is fake jurors could end up
watching hours of video evidence
including body camera footage from the
crime scene and police interrogations
there were live rounds on set they were
mixed in with regular dummy rounds
nobody was checking those or at least
they weren't checking them consistently
and then they somehow got loaded into a
gun as for the family of slain
cinematographer Helena Hutchins I had
been overcome by this anger today they
praised the decision to press charges
quote it is a comfort to the family that
in New Mexico no one is above the law
[Music]